III may be canceled this year for some
tweets from 2013 that didn't age well
and also a minor global catastrophe but
that didn't stop PlayStation from
announcing new things for us to be
excited about in these trying times hey
kids you want new consoles even though
it feels like these ones just barely
came out too soon my chronically
depressed tookest it's time for more
hardware that's going to cost half my
monthly salary to buy just so it can sit
on my shelf all day and only be used to
put on Netflix in the background at
night while I sleep because the noise
and a little bit of light is more
comfortable vertical game is on point
now you have a taco to insert your
fridge it's like a Jenga game of
instantly dated design philosophies
white technology age is like milk
where will I place such enigmatic totems
of contemporary consumerist failings oh
thank god you can put it on its side
look here's one with no disk hole it's
like a chastity belt of consoles and I
hope this idea dies immediately because
digital media doesn't belong to you and
can be taken away or shut down forever
at a moment's notice but my copy of
spider-man on ps1 still works fine after
20 years
speaking of spider-man and being asleep
spider-man 2 is not here yet so take
this instead the new generation of dead
uncle simulator is here now with dead
cop dads who are named what wait what
before a lot of footage to unpack here
of really high fidelity cutscenes that
will assuredly look sharper and more
cinematic than actual gameplay as well
as clips of stuff that looks like
gameplay but is actually also cinematic
footage that will cause everyone to
argue and get mad in six months because
it won't look exactly the same on look
at all there's puddles oh my god you
better hope those make it in the game
but that's okay because given their
track record and Sami X footage for this
showcase here will be close enough that
I won't be dissatisfied I know how video
games work man I get it I'm not mad I
love you can I have an Easter Egg in the
sequel I promise I'll be really good I
stopped fighting with my brother Papa so
while other people are a bit upset that
this isn't the proper numbered sequel to
Disney Sony's Marvel's Garth Mayer and
hi spider-man I think a side series
slash spin-off makes a lot of sense
considering the time frame it's only
been two years since PlayStation Man 4
came out and I'd be worried if the full
sequel was really done that quickly I
felt like it was too early to announce a
whole new game and typically the
development cycle for
something like that is at least four
years making games is a long and tedious
process where you have to watch lots of
lively gore footage compilations to make
your Mortal Kombat guts realistic enough
a lot of folks speculated that miles
would be like a second player co-op
partner for the sequel but it appears
that somme niak went the route of God no
I imagine it'll have a series of bosses
based on miles his own rogues gallery of
villains like uncle Prowler Deadpool
mask bombshells
even though those were Altima Peters
villains first cartel scorpion lady
electro Regent kind of himself from the
other unit I like this costume a lot I'm
surprised they didn't insomniac off' i
it a little bit more with an advanced
design but it's kind of hard to
reimagine this costume because it's so
simple and straightforward they did a
good job of giving a texture and detail
that makes it look like more than just a
bodysuit from the waist down I feel like
the Miles Morales costume could have a
really bad case of Ben Riley with no
hoodie syndrome where he looks like a
naked body painted guy instead of
someone wearing a costume see Superman
without trunks for further examples of
why this is an issue character design
kids you got to break up the colors and
add some seams or it looks [ __ ] weird
I think it's a no-brainer that the
spider-verse costume some super basic
comic version possibly with associated
filter maybe that new design with the
blocky or shapes
perhaps a few original designs will all
make it into the game the unlockable
costumes were such a huge element in the
last one that it would be a huge
disappointment to take that out I'll
understand if my pal Yuri won't be a
huge element in this game since we're
trying to give miles own room to exist
and that's cool by me what a tagline
come on someone has to have watched at
least one of my videos I'm not gonna
take credit but I will say that I was
one of the people that got the
conversation rolling you got to give me
that this game could go one of two ways
either it's a lost legacy sort of deal
where it's a spin-off game with a few of
the side characters highlighted and
it'll work mostly offer used animations
and assets to tell fun little emphases
on little Side Story as for the other
direction
my friend Dane said something that stuck
with me on the day of the announcement
some games are like a salad a salad
isn't really a full meal at most
restaurants but more of a promissory
note that a full meal will soon arrive
you know the kind of game where it's
almost all reused assets and animations
that were quickly cobbled together into
a new story in under a year or two to
tide you over while they work on the
actual sequel because the developer is
trying to make things work with new
console technology and they haven't
quite got it down yet
just just take this nice little salad
while we finish the steak set please
don't lose interest and leave our
establishment and go to McDonald's games
like resident evil 3 while waiting for
code Veronica to come out or the
divisive Arkham origins placed between
releases of the main line Arkham games a
little Spider Man edge of time while
they take the time to work on a big
open-world movie tie-in with new stuff
built from the ground up all salad games
a new term I'm proposing and that's
exactly what res evil 3 remake was a low
effort quick little salad with cut
content from an already annoyingly short
game full of breakneck pacing that makes
it far less satisfying than the polished
and well crafted experience from
Resident Evil 2 remake they were just
getting us to keep quiet for a year
while they worked on Resident Evil 4
times - now featuring zombie werewolves
and vampires which is a nice change of
pace from zombies after the two more
traditional games we just got it's nice
to get some variety in this series and
hopefully the emphasis will be more on
individual enemy encounters than
exclusively bosses like re 7 given that
the molded were so underwhelming of an
imposing NPC force I eagerly await to
see if this means they've brought back
the attache case mechanics from re 4
because I think it's one of the best
inventory mechanics in any survival
horror video game and I noticed it even
has an in-game currency does that mean
the beloved re floor merchant will be
making an appearance
I suspect the character shown here will
serve the same role as Clancy in re 7
being more of a side character to
experience the more dire events than
Ethan winters encounters I appreciate
the inclusion of Ethan winters because
he has more of an underpowered everyman
vibe than most of the characters in the
series having a long time given that all
of them trained it becomes super-powered
ninjas off screen who can do wrestling
moves on zombies and punch boulders look
they fixed Chris Redfield face now he
looks like himself again instead of this
weird project awakening Viking
all in all I'm very excited for the bold
new direction the series is taking with
new horror elements from several sources
of inspiration for each new installment
re7 thrived on Evil Dead Chainsaw
Massacre SAW and The Hills Have Eyes
sorts of aesthetics and scenarios in re
AIT's more gothic horror influences or
welcome changed of paces at this point
in the series
good work Capcom I'm excited to see more
but please maybe add something to our
III so it's not just the unloved middle
child of the series uh what were they
talking about I'm sorry I just got
distracted spider-man's just so boring
lately
[Music]
[Music]